on video I'd like to point out that we
met Drake together and Drake said he'd
get on a record but he also said he'd
give me because he made a bet what you
did he said he'd give me fifty thousand
dollars if the sons went further than
the Warriors two years ago and they did
oh you cashing in on that I don't I
mean I haven't seen him since damn he
ducking you but you were there I was
right there you can confirmed this you
didn't say that he said I give you
50 Grand if the he said the sons
wouldn't go into the finals he did Eric
LaRock was there he did say that so he
did say that Drake owes me 50 bands yeah
he do Drake you do leg calf 50 bands I
can't stand on that I want my percentage
good that's right